what's up fellow Geeks we've got the
nothing phone 2. it's sleek and has a
bunch of hardware and software updates
from the phone one and we'll be putting
it through the gauntlet of Kenshin
impact pubg mobile called mobile and
honkai stereo to see if the phone can
perform Under Pressure performance wise
the nothing phone 2 that we are using
has a Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 a adreno
730 for its GPU 12 gigs of RAM 256 gigs
of storage and everything plays out on
the 120hz flexible OLED ltpo 6.7 inch
screen with a 4 700 milliamp hour
battery before we run tests let's do a
baseline of the temperatures of the
front and back of the phone so adjust
the temperature going and let's check it
out
okay 28 it's a pretty cool phone it's
kind of glossy on the back yes it's
rounded glass on the back actually it's
quite an improvement over the original
phone and on the front
29 inch we are looking at numbers below
30 or just around 30 so not too bad from
the phone so far I mean we haven't done
anything yet alright so with that let's
play our first game Hong Kai style but
before that let's increase the volume
which is really cool because I've
enabled the glyph interface at the back
to track the volume meter so look at
that that is that is super cool oh and
there's a game mode as well I'm not
exactly sure how to oh wait here we go
here we go okay Bree down game dashboard
we have
full screenshot cards available we got
off we've got FPS counter cool uh do not
disturb and what's this recording
shotguns available so if you want to
record games you can do that through the
game dashboard and yeah okay
yeah they're going for us all right sick
all right let's move around but before
that let's check our settings
[Music]
okay so Graphics wise you're on very
high 60 FPS everything else is on high
and I believe empty yields and Heights
as well yes correct all right sweet okay
so that's settled let's just look at our
model real quick at our Traveler
Rosario
there we go and honestly on this screen
she looks really good and so far I
haven't noticed any like major frame
start doing anything like you've seen in
other phones
it's handling itself pretty well
you think that yeah
you think that a phone with a standard a
plus gen one and an adreno 730 that's
kind of behind some of his competitors
would do much worse but or even like
slightly worse but this is doing pretty
well so far
oh all right switch around
there are no fake there's nothing in
between that's oh this is great
and we are kind of hitting like a nice
consistency FPS with the Game Hub
counter so with that let's try out the
simulated universe
sound is great the size of the screen is
actually really good 6.7 inches for me
the right size
all right let's do a quick
bounce
very smooth actually wow
sick okay okay okay okay okay
very nice
sound effects animations are looking
pretty chill so far looking really good
very smooth nothing is breaking up let's
keep going
bounce
all right let's go for in ulti and see
how that works out
[Music]
oh all these are very smooth on these
things
running into me
[Music]
all right let's go for the ulti
very smooth
okay
let's hit the OT real quick
oh actually
it's okay
all right so one thing I'm up is that
the speakers there's only one speak on
the side which is like right here
there's no other speaker parts around
the phone so you do want to be careful
about that you can use Bluetooth
headphones to cut this issue but you
know you could just kind of have a nice
little stick here
so you can let the speaker do its thing
all right
[Music]
okay so before we hit the elite I think
this phone is kind of warming up a
little bit let me just check that out
real quick
just want to make sure
so the front we're at 30 years now it's
38 oh
that's a big jump 37 36 at the top here
at the bottom sorry it's 34 inch at the
bottom this is the middle of the phone
it's about 36 and this is the top of the
phone it's around 38 ish let's check the
back real quick
oh yeah it's heating up a little bit
here it's warm but it's not hot
39 at the back right here I believe as
usual this is where the chip is at in
the middle 35 ish and the bottom is
about 33. all right interesting
so let's just fight the elite
okay
it's all pieces are crazy right now oh
yeah it's a lot of things going on
sick very smooth no issues whatsoever
and once you're dropping like two frame
rates but that's expected so we do it
pretty well all right come on Rosario
let's go
rest in peace nice in both section now
this thing's gonna be a grind
there we go final fight
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
next
there we go
worth my while
you can do this
see the deal come on let's go just a bit
more
let's go shoot one more time
just in case it was because I can
[Music]
[Applause]
I still down let's do this sample
all right come on March
[Music]
that's it there we go battle is over
oh okay and with that let's just check
them pictures before we move on to the
next game so on the front you're at 42
degrees wow it's that hard okay I didn't
notice that but yeah 42 degrees at the
top in the middle is around 42 41 ish
and the bottom we are at 39. wow okay
that's that's pretty hot
at the back oh okay I teach them a lot
now
we're at 42 huh okay 42 at the top here
and the middle at 40 38 wow okay it's a
pretty cool bag and the bottom is 36 so
it's heating up on the front quite a bit
and on the sides as well let me see if
we can get that so on the sides we're at
35 ish I saw 39 just now
36 ish on the sides here
so yes it is heating up quite a bit as
we speak but besides the thermo
performance and so besides it okay so
besides the thermal management which
isn't the best of course this isn't a
gaming phone this is doing pretty well
you're still ironic a consistent 55 ish
there's 60 FPS so far so with that let's
move on to our next game Genji impact
all right we are hot off the heels of
honkai stereo we will add 100 battery
right now now we're down to 90 91 and
that's after close to half an hour of
gaming so you do the maths and yeah
eight to nine percent of your battery on
the highest settings
for half an hour that's that's pretty
that's a good deal right there so before
we get into Genji impact let's check our
temperatures real quick we are just off
honkai style once again and let's see 40
degrees Yeah okay yes cooled down quite
a bit
and by quite a bit I mean really quite a
bit and let's see top one's middle
middle is 40 39ish we it is cooling down
as we speak and the bottom on 38 so the
top ball is 40 in a bit yeah it's okay
it's cooling off pretty quickly well in
real time
check that again
wow okay all right it's cool now quite a
bit and let's check the back oh the
bottom was 37 just now in the back we
are at 37 here
and the middle is around 37.9 for some
reason and the bottom the Bottom's 35.
so it's cooling down pretty quickly
from that intense session so with that
let's move on to gentian impact okay so
now that we are in Genji impact let's
check settings real quick
all right graphics and here all right so
we are high on everything the highest
set things and we are at 60 FPS
everything is turned on crowd density
it's on high as well so let's check out
that look real quick and see how he's
looking and he looks really good on the
screen honestly like honkai stereo the
screen has yet to disappoint it's
looking really good and it's still
pretty smooth so far there is very
minimal frame stuttering compared to
Hong Kong style which had nothing so
yeah genjin is still a pretty good
looking game all right so with that
let's run through unizuma City all right
as you can see everything is sort of
rendered in pretty well and
there isn't much lagging or anything so
far all right let's open this up real
quick okay we are not really hitting 60
that consistently but it's doing pretty
well we dropped by about 13 14 frames
as you can see those are like drastic
frame rate drops or yeah look at that
wow we're not even hitting 60 on this
thing
so interesting to see
but it is quite smooth so far compared
to some of the phones we've tested
so with that let's see how this fares
like when we explore and hopefully get
into a fight let's see oh what's that
oh okay we're dropping quite a bit
33 55
try again
oh and here it doesn't all right
okay so with that let's just keep moving
and see what else there is to explore
here on here
and hopefully we can get into fight
drastic freeway drop wow we win by like
half or 16 like 30 FPS ish and lower
so quick fight yeah
yeah all right swapping out to hell yeah
all right
nope
Okay so
combat so far is pretty okay I mean
before you went up against like two
hilly chills so that isn't much but
let's see if we can find some more to
fight
and of course yes we do
all right that looks salty oh yeah okay
not to drop anything will drop by half
right here
oh come on come on
[Music]
all right this one boy's down
let's take out they don't with
ayata
okay cool quick come on
oh no this one I didn't want to do that
it's my bed
very nice and are there any more people
to fight I don't think so
some of these kind of kill the FPS by
half for some reason yeah yeah all right
let's go
I still can't get a hold of his name but
yep I mean aiming is pretty okay so far
all right let's try an ultimate just to
see how this fares
[Music]
okay uh kind of draws by like 10 FPS ish
it's okay I don't what do you guys think
just let me know in the comment section
what you think of that like which
obviously you know we will want the fps
to remain constant but for the specs on
this phone I think it's working pretty
okay so far so with this let's go over
to the spiral bits but before that let's
do a temperature check you're at 39 38
is at the top 40 ish it's actually not
too bad it's not heating up as much as
honkai stereo so that's great so far
36.5 at the bottom let's check the pack
39 at the top
in the middle it's 37-ish 36 ish at the
bottom we are running at 35 34. cost 35.
so okay do we not too bad not too bad
I've seen worse I've seen much worse on
Flagship phones so we're doing pretty
well
okay so spiral this time we're giving me
for my team compositions but okay look
at this we're in a confined area and
let's just do this thing
quickly
[Music]
all of these doing pretty well
almost constant
yeah
all right so far we're doing pretty good
oh and then ultimate very soon
all right
[Applause]
let's do this
very nice
all right
[Music]
okay nice
[Applause]
all right nice
that was quick that was fast no offering
jobs whatsoever it's pretty fun to play
with this phone
so let us continue by checking the
temperatures and moving on to the next
game Okay so
we are currently at 39.5
9 is in the middle three years in the
middle and at the bottom 35 so not much
of a change it's pretty consistent so
far
top part is about 38-ish I think that's
slightly lower okay it's about the same
actually the middle we're looking at 36
ish all right 36 years and at the bottom
we are looking at 35 ish so yeah it's
this phone is handling itself pretty
well obviously you know there's some
pickups when it comes to the open world
aspect of Kenshin impact but that's kind
of expected so with that let's move on
to the next game Call of Duty mobile
before we begin the Call of Duty mobile
this channel is supported by Brands who
help us improve our content and keep us
going so stay around for this sponsored
message meet
15 gaming laptop from
material design that not only looks good
but feels good thanks to its Ultra
lightweight chassis at only 1.98
kilograms give yourself the upper Edge
in gaming with its blazing fast
performance powered by the latest 12th
gen Intel Core i7h Series processor and
Nvidia RTX 4000 series gpus and stay
immerse with its nahimic twin speaker
sound system that provides an auditory
Feast like no other for more details
check out msi.com okay so before we get
into Call of Duty mobile let's check
temperatures real quick we are hard off
the heels of Kenshin impact and we're
currently at 86 we were at 91 so that's
a hmm how many percent is that that's
five percent of playing Genji impact so
far for about 15 minutes ish which isn't
so bad come on we were playing Hong Kai
for much longer and it only took what
eight nine percent so this phone is
actually doing pretty well in terms of
its power management a lot better than a
lot of phones out there actually right
let's check temperatures temperature gun
hold off engine impact 36 ish yeah this
handles okay it doesn't handle heat that
okay
okay 36 wow okay so it dissipates here
pretty quickly
all right 36 in the middle and at the
bottom 35 yeah this oh this thing
actually disappeared pretty well it
handles it pretty well all right so
let's check the top here at the back 35
wow okay all right this is you surprised
me nothing you really do surprise me and
35 at the bottom 33 at the bottom 34ish
so yeah it's it's a pretty cool phone in
such a short period of time so
oh cool stuff nothing with that let's
just move on to our next game Call of
Duty mobile
we are on the front page of Call of Duty
mobile and just look at the glint of my
AK and look at how the Shadows interact
with her face with a fringe and her face
this looks really good in person all
right so let's just check settings real
quick okay graphics and very high Max
frame rate
let's see multiplayer everything is
turned on and let's do the thing let's
start a Shader preload
[Music]
all right so now that the Shaded preload
is done let's start a game of wrecked
oh yeah okay when you restart the game
sorry about that make sure I get my
killer one for one here
all right look at this scope looks
pretty good and let's just go
all right so far animations are doing
pretty alright and we're playing
Hotpoint so we're gonna be oh come on
okay let's move on to the back
so far it's clean pretty smoothly right
[Applause]
nope
nice okay it's doing pretty well so far
and okay I think it's a little bit dark
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy come on okay
we'll see for now but I think
comes in the back here
[Applause]
the audio from the speaker is sufficient
enough for you to kind of know where the
enemy is at so this is actually doing
pretty alright
the screen size is pretty great for this
very nice
I think I think it's Bots but never mind
this is gonna have to be quite alright
so far
all right
maybe I can get a new comment because I
have so far 18 I need 12 more
so far FPS no drops for that whatsoever
no drops at all you're doing pretty all
right
here we go
[Applause]
nice okay so all the Call of Duty is
doing so well
solo
okay I'm not doing well enough oh boy
all right let's do this
after a single round I think you know
this phone can handle itself pretty damn
well we are currently at how many
percent 84 from 86 one match will take
you about two percent off of your
battery on the highest set thing so very
promising stuff so far let's do a
temperature check real quick all right
so with that let's check them pictures
real quick with 30 forests at the top
here which is doing pretty good I mean
honestly it's not warm at all that's the
the great thing about this phone so far
it cools off pretty quickly 34s in the
middle and at the bottom you're running
at 33. all right let's check the back
okay
we're at 34 ish 35 okay no gate just 34.
close to 35 though in the middle 34-ish
no water defaults and the bottom were 32
31 even okay but 32 degrees so okay I
mean without a doubt if this thing can
handle honkai pretty well Call of Duty
pubg no issues all right so with that
let's move on to pubg mobile okay so now
we are at the front page of pubg mobile
let's check settings real quick
and Graphics Okay so
we are on smooth for graphics film is on
Extreme and I think it's there four
times and yeah I think we are pretty
much set so with that let's just jump
into a game but also let me just enable
the FPS counter right here and let's go
all right so in the lobby things are
looking pretty good so far you can see
the reflections are going off of a
leather jacket and animations are pubg
mobile animations so I mean they are
always good I think we're gonna get so
and also because we're playing on my
pfps we saw that just now so you know
you're not going to expect the best
looking game out of this thing because I
know a lot of you out there want to see
how smooth the phone can handle High FPS
rates so we're still at 16 or here even
though we're in extreme so whatever
okay so the C130 looks really good
especially with this player's skin looks
really nice and let's see okay oh okay
I'm the jumper still that's very fun
let's go to school then
all right and let's wait till we get
somewhere closer to drop off all right
one two three let's go
okay we are moving very quickly enemies
I thought they were following me okay I
think they are all right so we are
moving towards school right now
let's go
very close to school
[Applause]
oh my gosh nope
I can't have that can we
go for this video nowhere
all right
[Applause]
you're gonna stop too far from school
okay I will stop paying attention
oh boy
okay I think we can beat the guy that
kind of landed in front just now
we can kind of get much further in front
okay we don't
we don't need to run it we need to gun
it I'll let my guys just Loop this place
first
okay there's nothing here
okay there should be stuff inside here
let's keep going oh come on come on come
on
no come on come on grab everything you
can okay so far so good
okay so this is the default
okay fighting fighting fighting let's go
let's help him out if we can
I see that but I'm still here
[Applause]
very nice I think our guys are gonna
leave it pretty well I am still hitting
that fire button that's not very good
and honestly it's kind of weird that
pubg mobile still hasn't implemented 90
FPS on a lot of devices like we saw in
the xiaomi ultra
for some reason I think it's to do with
the Snapdragon I mean the CPU and the
GPU on this phone but I think that I
think this one can handle like the FPS
pretty well once you unlock that we've
blend it in much hotter spots but yeah I
mean pubg runs damn smooth
okay I'm still hitting the thing God
damn it
I think possibly going inside you
somewhere
there we go that's one down very nice
okay okay
you finally found some transportation
and I have to be very careful not to
press the extra detail button I really
need to work out
stuff but yeah I think it's a lot of
fighting going on here
and this thing I want I want to get the
ball gun fights
I was eating one huh
they're only 22 remaining what the hell
okay but okay so while we have to look
oh okay don't mind do you have a fight
I can't get out oh boy
oh
damn it okay
so if it wasn't for that custom if it
wasn't for my button placement I would
have I would still be alive but with a
game of pubg oh this is embarrassing
honestly let's check temperatures real
quick we've been playing for a good
20-ish minute so far let's check
temperatures on the front at the top
here we have 36 very very low honestly
very low compared to other games you
play like Hong Kai and genjin so yeah
this is this one's doing very well
check the back
right and we are at 35 and 34 here and
the bottom you're running at 33. so yeah
pubg no so yeah pubg no no no issues
honestly really no issues with pubg so
with that let's just move on to my final
thoughts the nothing phone 2 was
actually surprised me the Snapdragon 8
plus gen 1 and adreno 750 combo is all
done a couple of phones that run
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 and adrenal sound 40s
gameplay for honkai stereo was smooth
throughout with virtually no frame start
during or even the slightest frame rate
drop though I'd say for Genji impact it
may need more optimization work because
there are some pretty drastic drops but
other than that it performs a lot better
than I expected it's 6.7 inch size is
perfect and the positioning of the
speaker really had some thought to it
because you're able to cut the problem
by covering or by gripping it in between
your fingers like this because it's
placed nicely at the edge the battery
can take a beating so far with all of
the games on the highest settings
thermal management is great because well
this thing dissipates heat pretty
quickly for a non-gaming phone better
than most gaming phones out there with
better specs nothing has done a more
than decent job they've done an amazing
job actually with the nothing phone too
again you will be surprised when you get
your hands on this cool as hell looking
phone with great performance but the
real question is would you get it let me
know in the comments below and also if
anyone has any recommendations to track
performance on these phones that come
into the office please let me know too
if you like what we do why not follow us
on our socials to keep up to date with
everything geeky and if you like this
video hit the like And subscribe buttons
it goes a long way want to see more
stuff check this out
[Music]
thank you